the United States under the orders of
President Joe Biden has executed a
strike which killed Al-Qaeda leader
Ayman al-zawahiri who worked closely
with Osama Bin Laden in the 9 11 attacks
and naturally right-wingers are
desperately trying to downplay and
dismiss this event which were it under a
Republican president they would be
demanding that the president be
enshrined in some kind of gold-plated
statue that's what they would be doing
if it were Trump who had announced this
and it's an incredible contrast that
we've seen over the last 24 36-72 hours
where on the one hand the Biden
Administration strikes a 9 11 terrorist
a major person on the global Wanted list
and on the other hand Donald Trump quite
literally downplays taking Saudi money
in this golf tournament that was played
an event being played at Bedminster his
golf course and says bizarrely nobody's
gotten to the bottom of 9 11. think
about that in the same weekend in the
same three four day period former
president Donald Trump
um cow Towing to the conspiracy
theorists with nobody's gotten to the
bottom of 9 11 whereas on the other hand
Joe Biden authorizes a strike that kills
one of the major actors in those 9 11
attacks now before we get into the right
Wingers falling all over themselves to
criticize Joe Biden I think it's
important to mention that any serious
Progressive who respects the rule of law
and due process and all of the stuff
that the right claims to respect but
actually doesn't reasonable progressives
can be generally concerned about what is
exactly the legal infrastructure for
when the U.S strikes these individuals
in other countries they aren't getting
due process that's absolutely true and
while I on a personal level have no
doubt whatsoever based on everything
that we've seen and read about Iman
al-zawahiri that this guy was guilty
that is my personal opinion and he
didn't get due process and of course you
can argue well this this is technically
part of a wartime situation that dates
all the way back well but that's
complicated too so I'm not downplaying
that at all that's not why the right
Wingers are angry that's not at all why
the right Wingers are angry so let's
first start with the announcement from
Joe Biden make it clear again tonight
that no matter how long it takes no
matter where you hide if you are a
threat to our people the United States
will find you and take you out
after relentlessly seeking zawahiri for
years under presidents Bush Obama and
Trump
our intelligence Community located
zawahiri earlier this year
he had moved to downtown Kabul to
reunite with members of his immediate
family
after carefully considering
a clear and convincing evidence of his
location
I authorized the Precision strike that
would remove him from the battlefield
once and for all
this mission was carefully planned
rigorously minimized the risk of harm to
other civilians
and one week ago after being advised
that the conditions were optimal I gave
the final approval to go get him and the
mission was a success
none of his family members were hurt and
there were no civilian casualties okay
so that's the announcement from Joe
Biden you would think that the right
would rally around this what a patriotic
big boy that Joe Biden did but no here
is Tucker Carlson saying you know
Biden's bragging about killing this
Al-Qaeda leader I don't feel any safer
if a speech boasting that he's killed an
Al-Qaeda figure in Afghanistan great
feel safer of course you don't nobody
does and the reason nobody feels safer
is that Tucker Carlson is friends with
Donald Trump is Biden's response to the
disaster in Afghanistan oh rather than
pause and learn from it maybe fire the
people responsible for not simply the
self-destructive withdrawal from
Afghanistan but also the pointless
20-year War there rather than do any of
that like a normal person would do Biden
immediately set off in another Direction
provoking yet another conflict this one
in Eastern Europe so look at this uh
Biden authorizes a strike that kills a
911 leader and Tucker says says I don't
feel any safer because of Biden's
withdrawal from Afghanistan which is
identical to what Trump's withdrawal
from Afghanistan would have been and he
blames Biden for provoking Russia's
invasion of Ukraine
reeks of desperation Senate minority
leader Kevin McCarthy posting to Twitter
we owe a debt of gratitude to the brave
Americans who took out the terrorist
al-zawahiri the Biden Administration
must provide congress with a briefing as
soon as possible to discuss the
Resurgence of Al Qaeda in the region
following his disastrous withdrawal from
Afghanistan so by uh Biden not getting
any of the credit from McCarthy Trump of
course would have had McCarthy praying
at an altar to him and the Newsmax
taking the dementia approach and the
covet approach saying well okay instead
of talking about the substance of this
terrorist being killed Newsmax Cuts in
and says Biden seems confused and sick
now
justice has been delivered and this
terrorist leader is no more
people around the world no longer need
to fear the vicious and determined
killer
the United States continues to
demonstrate our resolve and our capacity
to defend the American people against
those who seek to do us harm all right
so we told you we'd jump in and show you
some of this the president at the White
House the big speech he's got covet
again he got the recurring case the
rebound case I guess but uh they brought
him out they gave him the teleprompter
it doesn't seem too familiar with the
speech seems a bit uh a bit off base but
maybe he's still sick let's go now to
chief White House now that's actually
kind of funny how they dismissed the
entire substance and instead go with
like oh Biden has coveted again if this
were Donald Trump Newsmax would be do 24
hours of coverage with Trump uh you know
looking Victorious and as Alpha As Trump
can possibly look so immediately
downplaying all of it reasonable
concerns for progressives about all of
these types of killings but the right
just desperate desperate not to give
Biden any kind of win even by their
standards is the important point that I
would make
one of our long time sponsors Splendid
spoon is giving you 50 off as many of
you know I am not vegetarian but I think
eating plant-based is a great thing and
I do more of it consciously Splendid
spoon takes the work out of eating
plant-based by delivering ready to eat
plant-based meals smoothies and juices
right to your door Splendid spoon fits
into my day easily the meals are in my
fridge put them on the stove top or in
the microwave and I've got a great fresh
plant-based meal in a few minutes it
saves me time which is really useful
right now whether you're vegan or you
just want to add an easy delicious way
to have more plants in your diet
Splendid spoon is a great way to go
there are great dishes like creamy
mushroom and spinach noodles coconut
curry cauliflower Tikka soup that's one
of my favorites tons of choices the menu
rotates con instantly I've tried a lot
of different meal subscription Services
Splendid spoon is great on both taste
and quality they pack so much flavor
into the dishes they taste freshly
cooked Splendid spoons smoothies are
awesome when I'm on the go and you'll
get fifty dollars off your first week
when you subscribe at splendidspoon.com
Pacman the link is down below